well join me now to discuss all this is
sports broadcaster Bianca Westwood
talked to the contributor Esther kru and
Del mirror's associate editor Kevin
Maguire right right Bianca Westwood you
and I uh discussed uh recently Joey
Barton's comments about women pundits
and commentators and I was with you on
that I thought he was talking a loot of
nonsense actually about uh about the
women's commentary and punditry lineup
many of whom are absolutely excellent
and just as good by the way as many of
the men if not better right which is how
it should be you're there on Merit
you're not there because you're a woman
on this one I have a big problem I can
say that with what happened because I
think it sends entirely the wrong signal
I don't understand why she won other
than it's a public vote so a load of
women I presume and girls who love the
lionesses have
gone and she wins but she's not a worthy
winner it doesn't do women's sport any
good it doesn't do women any good the
number of women you've messaged me
honestly and said said you're so right
we don't want to win like this we don't
want to win just because we're women we
want to win because we win or we're as
good or better than the men what's wrong
with that did you vote
no well if you cared so much about it I
don't vote on any public votes why
didn't you vote ever since thebody
public voted to name a boat voting boat
face I realized they couldn't be trusted
right don't really have a leg to stand
on I don't vote all of those on social
media are so angry sure they didn't vote
I don't think it's my right as a uh
supposedly impartial television
presenter of a news and current affairs
show to vote in any of these things I
don't right so let's just park that to
one side all right well there's a few
key elements that here here's my
question did she deserve to win Prince
William was on Twitter today saying
hugely well-deserved Mary signed it w
why was it hugely welld deserved she
deserved it as much as anybody else
short list what did she win you have to
look at the criteria first of all I
actually didn't know what the criteria
for the sports Personality was so I
looked it up up it says it takes into
consideration the sporting achievements
of the last 12 months and the impact of
those achievements beyond the sport in
question I think that's key but if you
want to look at Mary Up's achievements
she was the only loser of the seven
nominees I tell you what she did win she
won the World Cup Golden Glove the fa
player of the year the FIFA Women's
world's best goalkeeper England women's
player of the year the WSL Golden Glove
as well she won that she was a World Cup
finalist she won the final eisma she
also won the Arnold Clark Cup as well
which is another inter how many actual
competi another International how many
competitions of country if any England
male player had won any of those or and
especially if they'd won all of them I
don't think we'd be having this
discussion really no I don't if Jordan
Gordon Pickford had won the best
goalkeeper in the world the fa best
player of the the season uh the Golden
Glove in a World Cup the Golden Glove in
the Premier League if he'd have won all
those would we be having this discussion
right now do you genuinely in your heart
believe that she is a worthier winner
than Rory maroy who's never won it
Ronnie O Sullivan who's never won it
Frank even on the short list for some
reason Frankie Dori has never won it
Stuart brao one of the alltime Greg
cricketers never won it none of these
guys have ever won it Ronnie wasn't even
nominated
but it takes into consideration the
sporting achievements of the last 12
months I don't know when they make the
short list maybe it was before Ronnie
had won the the UK that's a different
argument I'm not sure why he wasn't on
there but it's also about the impact and
you can't say that Mar UPS doesn't have
an impact in her that's interesting
point so my daughter comes home from
school today age 12 you know the first
thing she said to me yesterday she said
D she said I I had a great G of football
today I went what proper one she went
proper one I said what with with girls
she said girls and boys I said what
happened she we won and I said where did
you play she said but sender Midfield
deam rice I was like wait I love this so
I I completely love the impact the
lionesses have had on the nation's
females young and middleaged and old
whatever they want to be to play
football to watch football to love
football great right that's not for me
in debate it's great is that enough to
Warrant winning this well I think
obviously the answer is no but I think
bigger issue was with voting British
public as opposed to the fact that she's
on the short list because yes of course
there are the people that want it but
it's who's more visible right this this
woman is is is in in a position of
prominence particularly for young girls
who probably have never voted for this
they thought actually this might be the
first year I'll vote for this woman so I
think that's the bigger issue I do take
issue with the quip though about
Manchester United Mr Pier Morgan and I
will never forget that as as a
traumatized United fan I will remember
it wasn't a quip it was a statement of
fact You've Won absolutely nothing and
you're not going to because you got rid
of Ronaldo and ever since then you've
collapsed
and Eric ten has turned out to be
completely I need I need some Mental
Health Resources you can't it wasn't
equipped it was a statement of yes but
I'm deep I'm deeply hurt by it the can
be hurt by recovering from my illness
well then don't drive Ronaldo out of
your car right uh Kevin give me some
common sense take on this Pi look I'd
have voted for Steward broad but he
didn't win back the ashes he won the
moral ashes yeah but he didn't win back
the ash cheated didn't win back the the
ashes the fact is hers has got bags of
Personality she sells more shirts than
Jordan Pigford the male England keeper
and it's a sports Personality well she
qualifies for sports and she's got the
personality the last loser who didn't
win anything I mean look I put put
inside the individual Golden Gloves
that's all fine right you know but when
was the last person who actually was a
loser in a year to win that award the
ones I know think of Gaza Gaza won in
1990 England didn't even get the World
Cup final I thought he was a worthy
winner
1998 uh Owen Michael ow England didn't
get to the final look she got to the
final she won the Golden Gloves she's
inspired people like your daughter and
that's why she won all those people it
must be tens hundreds of thousands of
women have been inspired to play
football because of the likes of her and
that's why she's won my irritation about
it is that I think the others was are
such worthy winners and in terms of
Personality there is no bigger
personality in World sport than Frankie
Dori for example Ron O Sullivan the
documentary about his life is
unbelievable right he's won eight World
titles and never won this right um you
know you look at Stuart broad I mean one
of the all-time great cricketers you
could go through a whole list of them
it's really the one the men who haven't
won it yeah now being eclipsed by
somebody from the same team as the
winner last year and yet this year the
team did very badly to me it looks like
a reward for failure I do take your
point I mean I knew that not everyone
had won so I was curious whether you
knew and there's some valid point to
make the points you make about all the
individual things she's picked up is a
valid point to make the impact he's had
on the game is a valid point to make but
no one can convince me that this year
those men that were eclipsed shouldn't
have won it in St no that right they
have achieved more in their careers
unquestionably however they've had long
careers so in in a sense you don't get
the impact she has got because women's
football is taken off that's abely it's
like a volcano erupt and and that's why
people have gone but that's why they
were rightly honored last year with
almost every honor going including the
team War but they also won the
individual personality of the year which
was the I think she was the captain
right Beth perfectly good to do that I
just think it when you start rewarding
people for the failure of their team to
win anything which is really what it's
not that's not what they're rewarding
her for they're rewarding her for being
an exceptionally good female football
player who is inspiring people that's
that's why they she could argue that
she's having more impact on young people
than any of those other sport Sportsman
you know Ronnie as brilliant as he is is
is he inspiring uh you know an a
generation of young kids the failure of
a football player to not win anything is
down to the team as opposed to her as an
individual so we have to remember that
one thing I think we can agree on is
Joey Barton in his in his rant today
some which I agree with but in his rant
today he says he he said I'll score
eight a 100 out of 100 penalties against
Mary herbs any day of the week twice on
a Sunday here's my challenge to Joey Bob
right you do that let's set that up you
take a 100 penalties against her right
and every one you miss you give
£100,000 to a charity of our choice
you'd be bankrupt 100 Grand per missed
penalty right I reckon he'd be down a
few million right she's a good
goalkeeper right but the thing we can't
agree on he also said that he also was
personally abusive and said that she was
a sack of Spuds or something right she's
obviously a great athlete She's
supremely Fit she's at the top of her
game playing in World Cup finals and so
that kind of gratuitous abuse I think is
completely unacceptable and unnecessary
right so we can all agree on that that's
very different though uh to questioning
as you are why has she won when these
Sports people have over their careers
achiev I think Joey Bon is look he just
needs to get a life or get another
manager's job or a partner or whatever
whatever he just he's just again like a
teenage boy enjoying the attention from
the internet for the first time you know
that high where you're just incentivized
to say what comes to your mind I mean I
think the bigger issue with this award
is should she have been nominated in the
first place for not actually having won
anything I don't think it's the fact
that she won nomination I think I think
that's a good point yeah I think it's
the nomination not the fact that she won
because last year everyone no one had
any problem with Beth mewi because they
won the Euro fantastic right but I just
think that I'm not sure that women
should feel comfortable about this win I
think women should think you know what
this looks like box ticking but then you
have to look at the criteria what have
the others won in the last 12 months it
was propelled by a bunch of young
women never interested in women's
football he was the driving force behind
the winning of the rer cup the B one of
the biggest sporting events in the world
R Ma has never won this if england men's
football he didn't win an individual
major this year he won he won the
Ultimate Team event if if if england
men's football got the World Cup final
Jordan pford sun and lad played Blinder
all the way through best Keeper in the
game they lose one nil and he won it
would you really
well you know well you know I've already
said that when we when we lost the Euro
final I didn't think the men should have
won the team award but you wax Lial
about Gaza who was you know an
unbelievable player but in 1990 he
hadn't won a thing why is that okay
because he's
Gaza he was Gaza he was Gaza and he
cried in Italy and that's why he won it
DAV a more talented free kick against
Greece that was why he tell you because
he was the greatest footballer English
footballer think Ryan I've ever seen and
with greatest respect to Mary she
wouldn't get into gaza's junior team at
school right so let's be clear it's in
your chosen field we're notar saying
that football is if you're going if
you're going to compare men to wom
that's like saying cycling is the same
as Athletics you if you're going to say
sport if you're going to compare her to
Gaza I'm going to say Gaza was not only
hang best fi Not only was Gaza 10 times
better as a football player he just was
but secondly he had 10 times the impact
on the country right and if you don't
believe me go out and ask a 100 people
in the street tomorrow go down Oxford
Street ask them two questions who's Paul
gascoin and then say who is Mary hers
absolutely and even though she's just
won that award most of them won have
know heard of Mary herbs right I agree
with I'm not saying that they won't in 5
10 years the growth of the game is
fantastic nobody knew please don't try
and compare her to Gaza no but no I was
saying that because you had said that
you had to have won something he hadn't
won anything that year that's a Val
point he cried in Italy that is a valy
point and we all felt for
him they were magic Bal gas in 1990 Mike
alone in 98 didn't win but they inspired
people
and the same again that's it it's the
well I can only judge again if my
daughter's out playing football at Dean
rice and Center Midfield and ecstatic
about it something's happening
something's happening and I like it and
I like it so uh maybe I'm wrong Maybe
I'm Wrong maybe you persuaded me good
you know what you put up a very good
defense thanks P which doesn't surprise
me because you you're very capable but
anyway I appreciate it all thank you
very much
indeed